[Música]
la llegada del fenómeno del niño ya es
oficial la Organización meteorológica
Mundial confirmó que por primera vez en
siete años existen en el océano Pacífico
Tropical las condiciones que podrían
causar Un aumento de las temperaturas y
fenómenos meteorológicos extremos el
patrón climático del niño ocurre
típicamente cada dos a siete años y
suele durar a 9 de 9 a 12 meses para
entrar o para analizar esta información
conectamos con Federico Gómez Delgado él
es oficial profesional de la oficina de
la Organización Mundial meteorológica
para Norteamérica Centroamérica y el
Caribe Federico Bienvenido a directo
América Muchas gracias primero Cuáles
son puntualmente estas condiciones que
detalla la Organización meteorológica
Mundial para declarar oficial la llegada
del fenómeno del niño
y la el establecimiento de este fenómeno
usualmente se basa en la el seguimiento
de ciertos seguidores e indicadores por
ejemplo las temperaturas de la
superficie del mar en el Pacífico
Tropical y muy particularmente en las
partes central y oriental del Pacífico
Pero además eh la interacción de estas
temperaturas con los niveles de presión
atmosférica También en esta misma región
Son son indicadores muy importantes de
no solo del establecimiento de fenómenos
sino de la propagación del fenómeno y
los posibles impactos
a nivel mundial no obstante cabe aclarar
que en el caso de la Organización
meteorológica Mundial se hace una
coordinación a nivel mundial como como
su nombre lo indica de modo que contamos
con
predicciones y análisis de diversos
centros mundiales de producción de
predicciones a largo plazo y otras
fuentes de información y análisis
procuramos este conciliar a la hora de
hacer este tipo de comunicados Federico
este fenómeno meteorológico se relaciona
con un aumento en las temperaturas y
sequías pero los expertos explican que
en otras zonas se producirían Fuertes
lluvias y lo hemos visto por ejemplo en
China lo hemos reportado aquí en Francia
24 como estas inundaciones yanca están
empezando a causar la muerte de personas
explícanos Cómo funciona esto
Pues el tema es que el calentamiento
gradual en estas zonas del Pacífico
Tropical Vera central y oriental
como dije logra incidir en los patrones
de circulación a nivel mundial y también
la dirección de los vientos Entonces al
al tener estas perturbaciones se pueden
se generan conexiones o teleconexiones
que se llaman verdad que generan
impactos en muchas otras regiones No
necesariamente aquí y es por eso que por
ejemplo tenemos una concentración de
lluvias frente al Ecuador norte de Perú
a veces la zona central de chile pero
también al sur de Estados Unidos en el
cuerno de África y en Asia central en
este caso verdad no obstante los efectos
del niño también pueden generar sequías
al mismo tiempo por ejemplo en la parte
Norte y centro de Sudamérica
Centroamérica El Caribe y en Australia
Indonesia y el sur de Asia entonces no
es no es algo evidente verdad Pero sí
son cosas patrones que ya se han
identificado
al analizar fenómenos anteriores del
Niño ahora porque en estas zonas
específicas existe este este tipo de
pronóstico
claro aquí el tema es que al tener
cambios drásticos en zonas de alta
presión en la atmósfera
particularmente por ejemplo se ubican
sobre Australia Norte y centro de
Sudamérica se crea una redistribución de
todo el patrón de lluvias de humedad
verdad todo esto son fluidos desde el
océano verdad en estado líquido en
estado gaseoso en la atmósfera
y todo todo esta dinámica de cambios de
temperatura hace también que la dinámica
propia de los fluidos como el como el
aire como el agua se modifique verdad Y
eso es lo que genera en este caso
distintos patrones a los que ocurren
Cuando no tenemos este este foco digamos
de calentamiento
tan estratégico ahora no solo los
fenómenos meteorológicos son
consecuencia del niño por ejemplo la
Organización Mundial de la Salud habla
ya de riesgos e inseguridad alimentaria
e incluso de transmisión de enfermedades
infecciosas Cómo se encadenan estas
problemáticas con la llegada del niño
pues naturalmente acá el asunto es que
las tendencias de de temperatura las
tendencias de precipitación influyen
directamente por ejemplo En
estacionalidad distribución de las
enfermedades infecciosas pero también
desencadenan eventos meteorológicos
extremos que amenazan de otra maneras
verdad y y de maneras muy
interconectadas en medios de
subsistencia como en este caso de temas
de seguridad alimentaria verdad
especialmente Pues en las poblaciones
más vulnerables
los ciclos climáticos interfieren
también con los ciclos hidrológicos
verdad Y esto me modifica los patrones
normales que son los con base en los
cuales normalmente las poblaciones y los
medios productivos planifican sus
actividades
y aparte de también exponer a los
humanos a otros peligros atmosféricos
naturales pero también
los antrópicos verdad como diríamos las
radiaciones ultravioleta otras formas de
radiación etcétera y bueno es justo por
eso que la Organización meteorológica
Mundial en particular ha venido a través
de los años reforzando su colaboración
con organismos como la OMS la etcétera a
fin de acelerar el acceso a servicios
meteorológicos y climáticos para que
estos sectores puedan entender mejor
estos impactos y predecir mejor lo que
va a ocurrir Federico al ser este un
fenómeno que se repite cada cierto
tiempo es posible afirmar que los
episodios anteriores han hecho que por
ejemplo gobiernos y organizaciones
internacionales estén mejor preparados
para una situación como ésta
de acuerdo al sistema de seguimiento del
desempeño de la omm en un informe
recientemente publicado en julio del año
pasado si bien se ha hecho un esfuerzo
muy importante a nivel nacional
hoy día relativamente pocos países
cuentan con un sistema de alertas contra
amenazas múltiple y que estén basados en
una legislación nacional y Marco
regulatorios para poder responder a
estas emergencias
de manera oportuna y en vista de los
retos actuales verdad A veces también si
usted tiene legislación pero no
necesariamente está adaptada a las a las
actuales condiciones
También es importante a nivel a nivel
internacional mencionar que las Naciones
Unidas desde el año pasado
está impulsando una iniciativa llamada
alertas tempranas para todos Que
pretende una ambiciosa meta de cubrir un
100% de la población mundial con este
tipo de sistemas en los próximos cinco
años bueno Esto se lanzó el año pasado
así que nos quedan cuatro pero la
ambición de este programa es seguir
apoyando a los gobiernos nacionales
verdad Para que se desarrollen Estos
tipos de sistemas de alerta en el caso
de la omn en particular relacionados con
tiempo clima e hidrología pero que
también deberá abarcar otros ámbitos de
de de amenazas que afectan a las
poblaciones
Federico Gómez Delgado oficial
profesional de la oficina de la
Organización meteorológica Mundial para
Norteamérica Centroamérica y el Caribe
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos con el
análisis en este importante tema que ya
del que ya se advierten ya varias
consecuencias como lo es niveles
extremos de consecuencias climáticas
Muchas gracias
muchas gracias a ustedes y ustedes
televidentes también gracias por
sintonizarnos volvemos en minutos con
más información esto es directo América
[Música]